e
we have a a busy week ahead a couple of
busy weeks ahead uh trying to finish up
all of our
bills um and we have uh the morning
starting with a couple of hearings so
maybe we can uh begin with the pledge um
representative Woodcock would you like
of the United States of America and to
the it stands
Nation
all thank you and we'll open up our
first hearing um of the morning which is
House Bill 749 requiring high schools to
include instructions on the nature and
history of Communism and uh I do see the
prime sponsor and uh former education
Committee Member representative mfet
welcome
back thank you Mr chair it's nice to be
back in room 207 or I guess you're in
207 I think I'm in
205 um so uh yes for the record uh uh RS
on Mike Mett marac for towns of
Canterbury in Lowden and uh so years ago
a few years ago there was at my daughter
daughter's yearbook and looking at the
U the club photos and the sports team
photos and everything that's in the
yearbook and I saw that her High School
had a communist club which I did a
double take on said whoa communist club
and um he said uh Katie you're not in
the Communist Club are you and I didn't
know so I asked a few questions about
that and it got my attention and it
troubled me a little bit uh although
this is America and we you know believe
in Freedom of of uh Speech so this bill
simply requires a minimum of 1 hour of
classroom study regarding the origin and
nature of Communism it's been inspired
by that experience but also many other
numerous conversations over time with
parents and citizens who are concerned
that students and young citizens
today simply don't understand some
relevant and compelling history that uh
they should
and so many schools no longer teach
history like they used to uh every
school's different of course um I taught
us history in several high schools in
New Hampshire and the challenge was
always to do justice to the 20th century
uh and I taught a good number of years
ago and by the time the semester was
coming to a close you trying to hustle
up and get into into through the 20th
century and that was when I was school
myself 50 years ago now there's 50 more
years of History so it's a challenge I
know very well to to teach history math
is kind of a finite body of
knowledge but history just keeps growing
so I understand that challenge so the
question comes why communism okay why
not include some in requirement for a
bit of instruction on uh musini Islam
fascism Aryan Nation uh anarchism
whatever and theed these and other
movements certainly do rate attention
and and study of course but to try to
include everything in this proposed
statute uh would just be unwieldy uh
educate educated citizens in America
today I feel many of us feel need to
understand what communism is and how it
shaped our history and how it shapes us
today
profoundly uh dictionary a dictionary
definition calls communism a political
the drive from Carl Marx advocating
class advocating class
Warfare resulting in all property being
state-owned and this involves uh by
necessity a centrally planned economy as
opposed to one that reflects Market
forces I think most all of Y all know
that but without exception communist
countries depend upon vast networks of
secret police to impose the party will
on everyone the communism is a one part
involves a one party State there's no
multi-party communism controls
everything it's an atheist totalitarian
ideology that's incompatible with free
democracies everywhere it just can't
compete with free democracies that's why
they try to undermine free democracies
that's why they tried to oppose us for
for a
century and undermine us they still are
so throughout the 20th century communism
resulted in repression lag prison camp
starvation endless violent conflicts
subversion both hot and cold Wars Soviet
Union was born in violent Bloodshed you
all hopefully know that 1917 Russian
Revolution uh which established the
common turn the Communist
International the mission of which was
to spread communism everywhere at all
costs so we quantify the C that cost and
lives uh in 2010 Professor Steve rosi
wrote in red Holocaust the Communist
regimes caused the killing of at least
60 million
people perhaps tens of millions more
than that that doesn't even include the
25 million Soviets who died during World
War II victims of a deal between Stalin
and and Hitler Nazi by the way is short
for national socialism which is in many
ways not totalitarian movement similar
but not identical to Communism
so Stalin's Legacy remains and indeed
communist nuclear missiles are pointed
at us
now speaking of nuclear missiles I know
that there are others here a couple
others besides me who remember the Cuban
Missile Crisis of
1962 I know the representative from
Salem probably doesn't remember that but
I know some of us do uh I was a second
grader for a week or two that October it
was terrifying those of you like me that
are old enough to remember uh when when
the adults all around you are scared to
death that the world's going to end and
you're 7 years old that that week or two
weeks in in that October still uh
resonates uh my dad explained that if if
or when the bombs came we'd go to an
underground fallout shelter beneath the
groon paper mill I know the
representative from B is from my
hometown I don't know if if she remers
having some guidance on where to go when
the missiles come when the bombs come
fortunately they did not come but how
many students they have a clue about
Cuban Missile Crisis or the Korean war
or the Vietnam War how many know about
the Vietnamese boat people uh result of
a communist reg regime so heinous that
Vietnamese got into boats and headed out
to sea where hundreds or even thousands
drowned whether they were raped or
killed by Pirates or were captured
recaptured by the Communists and sent to
re-education camps for years by the way
Secretary of State scanland sent me a
message in session the other day and he
called me asked like sub by his office
and he indicated that the archives they
found all kinds of material from the
Vietnam memorial when it came to New
Hampshire and there were bags and boxes
of memorabilia left there and he pointed
out the 50th anniversary of the end of
the Vietnam war is next month and so
anyway uh he's looking at a 50-year
commemoration that's just a quick
aside so anyway both people uh there
were lucky few who made it to America
they get it they understand they lived
it they survived it and and a lot of
these folks and we have some in our
legislature who come some co-sponsors
who came here from communist countries
and they get
it and next to Vietnam is Cambodia same
time as Z people there were over 2
million cambodians murdered genocide
between 75 and 1979 how many Americans
know about the Cambodian Killing Fields
do these millions of deaths rate any
historical
awareness uh Reagan correctly called the
Soviet Union an evil empire I believe
and and that that communist entity the
Soviet Union after World War II created
the Iron Curtain which we grew up with
many of us uh how many high school
students to they know about the Iron
Curtain how the Russians suppressed all
those countries East Germany in 53 they
tried to revolt hungarians in 56 Czechs
in' 68 the polls and on and on so the
Soviet Union imploded in 1991 communism
just could not survive itself in in that
Empire Soviet Union imploded in
countries broke into many other
countries but communist Lon Russian
Russia authoritarian today uh it's its
leader Vladimir Putin is a classic
communist he's a head of the KGB and uh
we everybody I think does know what he's
up to and how that impacts us today all
of us the whole
world and he started this Ukrainian War
as we know
so many of us are concerned that so many
young people don't have a clue about
Stalin Lenin Mau Iron Curtain Sputnik
Bay of Pigs Cuban Missile Crisis glassos
perista the rosenbergs who are the
rosenbergs why do we execute this
American couple what's a gulag what's
the deal with these Chinese spy balloons
flying over our heads why does Taiwan
matter I visited Taiwan island of
Freedom 17 months ago talk about Live
Free or Die those people in
Taiwan uh have this met this gigantic
Menace that wants to take him over and
uh having been to Taiwan and and seeing
how thriving that free democracy is uh
and knowing that this humongous Chinese
uh entity wants to swallow him up uh
could that be a flasho
for a World War uh maybe and I think so
it's something that people need to
understand better so with a 1H hour
classroom session on the origin and
nature of Communism matter I think so
yeah yes especially the current lack of
history courses in in many schools again
every school is different some do better
than
others uh with these communist nuclear
missiles train on us with what's going
on in the Middle East what's going on in
Ukraine what's with Taiwan on and on so
this proposed statute does not require
any course I was just talking to
attorney Fenton about that I have been
in the classroom been in this committee
I'm very sensitive to how folks don't
appreciate us saying you need to do this
and and doe has plenty on its plate so
by Design This is a minimal 1 hour uh
proposed requirement in the history
nature of Communism could local control
can be embedded in an existing course of
some
sort um it simply the measure simply ask
the students spend that one hour um on
the history
communism
so if this did move forward I'm sure I
just talked to Diana that Doe would
issue an advisory and guidance on how to
implement it again every school might do
it differently there's a wonderful video
right now a biography on Stalin that's
uh narrated by Mike Wallace it's that by
itself is a wonderful tool that would
pretty much satisfy the requirement if
if if some school wanted to use that of
course some will go well beyond this
minimal 1hour requirement if it moves
forward and that's fine again local
control and just the fact that there's a
some sort of a discussion or debate on
this uh in schools matters people will
be talking about it learning asking
questions learning would happen
hopefully that's what we're about here
is is
learning and uh thank you for your time
i' be happy to take questions if if
there are any thank you representative
questions represent
NATO thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this forward uh and
enlightening on this on us you think I
know you said a minimum of one hour do
you think that is even enough for it to
uh really set home with these kids on
the to so we can actually maybe stop
this
uh socialis or communism uh because it
is pretty and is it's widespread amongst
some other countries do you think 1 hour
is sufficient thank you for your your
good question do I think one hour is
sufficient uh I would like to see a
whole course I would like to see a lot
more than that but as I said earlier am
very sensitive to us imposing things on
on schools so I I think I'm comfortable
with this this minimal ask uh yes I I
wish it would be more but I do think
representative that if if this did move
forward and if there was this 1H hour
requirement that Doe would put out an
advisory about so that every school
would have to pay some attention to it
that out of that some some discussion
would go well beyond that uh depending
upon the class and school and the
teacher so uh I I wish there was more
but I I feel okay asking for an hour
hoping that it'll lead to much more than
that locally uh on its
own thank you very much thank you than
you for the questions representative
Hall thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so in these State
Standards right now for social studies
is this in there at
all thank you for your question with
regard to what's currently in there uh
with regard to State stand standards I
don't believe there's anything specific
to Communism per se um which is why we
brought the this forward uh specific to
uh the communism by name
uh is an ideology I know there are
Holocaust studies in fact I just spoke
with the representative about which
section of Statute this if this moves
forward it might best go under should it
go under uh existing Holocaust uh
statute or the the one that OS
originally assigned it to uh you can
make a case for Holocaust uh in the
1930s the Soviet Union had imposed a
famine on Ukraine and like three to four
million people styed that was certainly
a genocide that was a holocaust of sorts
so in terms of where this might best fit
into statute if it moves forward uh
there's some flexibility there that you
all could
consider thank you representative Terry
thank you and thank you for that uh
thumbnail uh refresher of um the the
nature and history of uh communism
appreciate it very much especially as
somebody who's as keenly interested in
in history as I am um you mentioned your
daughter uh coming home uh with her High
School yearbook and that you um saw that
there was a communist uh Club in in her
school um with respect to this
particular bill that you're proposing do
you have any um knowledge or awareness
of Communism currently being treated in
the classroom room in in history courses
social studies courses or perhaps being
overlooked or is this more of a
proactive stance that you're taking to
to make sure that it's insured
regardless of what's going on currently
thank you for the
question as I said a couple times every
school is different and the intent of
this is both reactive and proactive I
think it's reactive in the sense that I
and others are have seen things uh I
mentioned the Communist Club
uh I've seen things and heard things
anecdotally and and also I've taught on
the colge level and I've I've get
getting a sense that uh this is why I
was so big on Civics education I've
gotten a sense from teaching in college
for 20 years that so many young folks
and older folks in college just don't
know what we wish they knew about
government history and specifically in
this case uh communism and the impact
communism has had and is having on us
and the threat threat that uh we think
that it is so I I would say this is uh
both reactive and proactive as as I
said further questions represent
Woodcock thank you
chairman morning again I do enjoy your
back my wife enjoys your sport column so
you right occasionally um thank so my
sports column is on hi this uh at the
moment if if your wife hasn't noticed
there are newspapers are not what they
used to be they're having to compete
with this thing called the internet so
uh we'll we'll see if that Sports column
comes back but I really appreciate your
wife reading it yeah she did I never
read it but she
like seriously though serious
considering the the current status of
Russia and Ukraine right
now
um it's hard to conceive that in public
schools between social socities
standards and of course the ones that
came out of jela and the current Civic
requirements but this being such a small
one-hour piece isn't being covered I
mean you just can't jump in and talk
about Ukraine or Russia without at least
some exploratory information foundation
so I wonder if this is not
duplicate yeah thank you for the
question uh I want to think and I have
to think that of course Russia and
Ukraine are being talked about in some
fashion I hope everywhere because it
impacts us I know uh with with the
elections and everything and the new ad
Administration taking a different tilt
in that regard uh it's being talked
about but the intent of this is to is to
ensure specifically that uh the history
nature of
Communism it at least washes over every
student because they have some context
for what's happening with Ukraine and
Russia Today I how many people know that
Ukraine was was part of the Soviet Union
Ukraine gave up its own nuclear missiles
for its independence of course the
Russians screwed them time and again
before they took Crimea so unless folks
understood the context in the history of
Ukraine being part of that communist
Empire if they did and I'm sure a lot of
people don't know that so the point to
try to answer your question is to have
this 1hour requirement I think I hope we
believe it would wash over everybody and
it would help provide some historical
context to things like Ukraine and
Russia in this war that threatens to
involve Europe and us so hopefully that
touches
on thank you for the questions yes
represent thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question I was
wondering if you know what the
requirements are for high school
students in New hampsh relative to world
history in other words like world
history courses is that a requirement of
high school students in New Hampshire
thank you for your question it used to
be I know that's changed and the latest
statute I know uh attorney Fenton's here
and some of you probably know that uh
world history used to be a requirement I
had to take it uh representative from Bo
probably had to take it maybe we had
some of the same uh gron High School
teachers but I believe that that's I I I
know that has changed that requirement
uh over time so world history uh I do
not believe as currently required as it
used to be uh should it be uh I well I'm
a history guy I think it should uh but I
know the stem people this is a problem
we all want stuff that we think is
important to be required and there's
only so much teachers can do I get that
again it's why it's only an hour so as
to world history I don't think it's
required but I'm sure somebody can
further questions representative
litfield thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I noticed
that this mentions both public and
private schools which isn't typical is
that do you consider that a slippery
slope to go down thank you for your
question with regard to should this be
uh required of private schools I taught
uh at gron high school I taught at
Trinity High School Public School
Parochial School when I in Trinity or
parochial school or private school I if
they're under the
umbrella of the doe in some fashion
charter schools public schools parial
schools whatever then this is intended
to apply to all students in such schools
whether they're P public or private
because we think all high school
graduates should have certain things
wash over them um whether it's English
or or this or whatever so yeah yes we we
want all students to uh be exposed to
this R muray um thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question as the
aunts of uh Cambodian Americans who fled
C Rouge I I deeply understand your your
point um but I I also am curious about
um when we're talking about communism we
are also having a conversation about
many other components that are deeply
interrelated and I am curious to know if
you have done any surveys or garnered
any data thus far that would tell us how
many districts within uh throughout the
state are teaching things like like this
or many other Concepts that we would
think are important just as sexism
racism ableism all of those types of
things do you have hard data on whether
or not this is already being taught sure
that's a great question and the answer
is is is basically no I I have not
personally resource all the uh scores of
high schools to see what what's
happening
locally and to touch on what you all
also touch on with regard to other
things that rate attention uh I
mentioned at the beginning of my remarks
that there are other ideologies that and
I mentioned some of them that certainly
rate
attention uh we focused on this one uh
because this is the the
one what we s the sponsor see is the the
largest most significant one that also
encompasses as I mentioned earlier uh
communism
totalitarian type of government was
similar to Nazism so to understand
communism better uh will help people
understand the whole
totalitarian uh thing mindset better as
well but I I I get your point and it it
goes back to us wanting to keep this to
just an hour because as you point out
there's so many other things that people
should be aware of but this is one we
think that we we could drill down on and
requirement thank
you R Woodcock quickly please just a
quick uh in in the weeds like the the
way this is written right now it doesn't
include chter schools the CH school is
not identified
so it's child School are exempt from
this and I'm trying to figure out how
private and non-public schools um
nonpublic schools can be can be required
how can I require St Michaels of Bo to
teach this um if in fact it's a private
school private parochial school and
there's no requirement to do that thank
you for your question that's a good
question charter schools are public
schools and we have a charter a new
Charter School in my town of Lowden that
I've been involved with a little bit and
I interpret the intent of this and the
execution of it if it moves forward is
applying to loud and Elementary well it
would be High School uh Public Charter
School should be covered by this and uh
Public Schools I I mentioned earli to a
different question in terms of parochial
schools I I've taught in both uh TR
Trinity uh was required to to
do the satisfy the same uh graduation
requirements as public schools in fact
uh this is back in the early 80s when I
went from a public school to teaching at
Trinity Trinity had no Civics uh at the
time no New Hampshire history and
government and that had become a law in
the early 80s so when I started teasing
a triny they looked at me and they said
uh can you start a course in seic New
Hampshire history and government because
it's a state requirement now that they
felt they needed to satisfy so I did so
to your point uh charter schools public
schools our Public Schools this should
cover them and as I said earlier
parochial schools should be uh covered
by this as well of course the committee
owns this and can amend it uh or enhance
it just just just to be clear um it
doesn't cover child schools it can't be
amended to cover child School current
wording does not you're right it is a
I would be
just I would be fine if uh again the
committee owns this if if the committee
wanted to clarify and ensure that uh
charter schools are clearly covered by
this uh one hour requirement uh I I
think that would be great thank you
thank you very much for bringing this
forward thank you Mr
uh uh good morning for the E my name is
y po representing M Mar hook D button uh
and I'm here to
testify uh in support of this bill uh
uh on the uh mostly I'm here to answer
questions because because representative
mafit I believe covered very well what
issue at
hand uh and
uh
uh uh I have some personal experience uh
um being Survivor from communist country
I happened uh to be uh born uh in Soviet
Union uh what in second largest city
what was then called
Leningrad uh so that was uh my childhood
being born in late'
70s um uh the only other thing I want to
mention that I I I like that this bill
is very short but uh uh I uh would
suggest you to think of any uh further
instructions needed uh because uh we are
saying that in ruction on the nature and
history of
Communism uh so uh I think the intend is
like uh to instruct how communism is not
a good thing but Bill doesn't directly
says it and we know like that some
Americans actually have favorable
opinion about uh communism and socialism
and the same clue about Educators and
maybe especially true that some of
Administrators who will be creating
these programs might think favorably of
these Concepts uh so uh my uh my
preference is like teaching kids
critical thinking so uh not just saying
oh this is just bad or this is just good
uh giving some history why why some
people thought that it's a good idea and
what we consider quences and what a good
size bad size bad size so I don't know
if it needs to be in a statue but that's
my preference and um I just uh an
example not necessarily saying that it's
happening in school but my small kids
came from her
educational uh organization and she
saying to me Father wouldn't it be
wonderful if we had no money and we
wouldn't need
money I was a little bit scared because
it's one of the selling point of
Communism like oh you struggling with
pain you're struggling with money let's
get rid of
money everyone with everything will be
just distributed without any money so so
those ideas are around us whether we
call them communism or not and it's
important to teach kids critical
thinking like uh why why it's why it's
appealing but why it might be not a good
idea in the real world and what could be
bad consequences if we go along with
that thank you thank you very
much uh any
questions see none thank you very much
for being here this
that way okay guys change this up all
the time thank you chair and thank you
committee my name is Christine Downing
I'm from Goan New Hampshire I'm a
30-year Public School educator of which
15 of those years have been spent in
curriculum Administration so I'm
actually here to put that hat on um
while I could not conduct a full State
review I did conduct a review of the
eight high schools in my region that my
schools sent to and my research involved
reviewing their program of studies as as
well as reaching out to their social
studies Department chairs and I found in
all eight cases um here's what I got for
some responses we absolutely cover this
in much more than an hour um in some of
the courses where you'll see it in their
program of studies is government classes
world history um a couple schools
actually have what they call comparative
um government courses uh Global Studies
and um about half of them even told me
they bring it into their economics
classes so it is being covered um and so
for that reason I oppose this because I
think this is unnecessary legislation
and I would actually offer um a
different pathway for this I certainly
recognize um the sponsors of this bill
and their passion behind it um and our
schools do want to do this topic Justice
and I do call it a topic because it
really is um content that lives in a
curriculum and I would like to remind
folks that RSA 193e
part 2A sections five and six clearly
delineate that curriculum instruction is
left up to the local districts and
curriculum in that RSA is defined as the
skill and the academic content that is
embedded in courses and programs of
studies and this is definitely an
academic content that we would want to
embed in our curriculum so nobody is
really opposing this topic it is
important to our schools we do want to
offer it so the the suggestion or the
pathway I might give this governing body
is that this um academic content topic
could be included in the update to the
2006 State social studies standards and
the curriculum Frameworks now that the
department of Ed is now responsible for
thank you to representative Lads bill
that was signed into law last year that
put our curriculum Frameworks back in
place um and do keep in mind that the
new 306 rules the updated 306 rules
created a section that made it clear on
how the department of Ed establishes its
State academic standards and that the
rules are very clear that um at a state
level schools are expected to integrate
those State academic standards into the
competencies that we locally develop to
delineate our credits and our courses so
I think this topic is very worth while
for our students to study I just don't
think it needs to live in an RSA I think
it really needs to live in where we
would design our curriculum
incompetencies around and I think you
have a pathway to do that through the
306 rules and through the Departments of
Ed oversight on State academic standards
and curriculum Frameworks thank you for
your time thank you very much for being
here represent Murray thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
if I'm hearing you correctly one concern
as a curriculum expert that you do have
is that potentially stating it being um
in Statute in addition to the one hour
time frame is that it actually could do
a disservice and actually um undo
learning and teaching that is currently
occurring by your standards and your
surveys thank you representative Murray
for your question I do think it would
cause confusion I I honestly don't think
schools are going to lessen what they
probably already do around this um I
just think it would create confusion in
the field and I and I think if you
really want this to be
sustainable um and really have impact to
our students that this can simply be
seen as a compliance checklist and and I
don't think we want that for our
students around this topic so that's why
I I have put that suggestion out there
that I really think embedding this into
the State academic standards getting it
in the curriculum Frameworks um that the
department of Ed can put out will really
put people on notice in particularly the
people people I'm talking about because
those are the direct documents that our
teachers can work with um and Implement
thank you for your question represent
litfield thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um so I heard
what you were saying about in the
schools eight schools within your
District are teaching this forgive my my
ignorance you listed the courses pretty
quickly oh sorry are these um are these
core courses that this is being
discussed or are these electives where
this is being discussed no actually all
these courses are listed are part of
graduation requirements um and just to
answer the question I know that came up
earlier I'm a curriculum person I know
the graduation requirements actually the
world history credit right now as it
exists today is a half credit but
starting in the fall of 2627 with the
adoption of the new 306 rules that is
going to shift to a full credit um so
again I I really think and this I love
the topic again respect the sponsors for
bringing it Forward I just don't think
you need it in law I think there's more
practical ways we can get this to happen
um and the last thing I think I would
add um representative litfield is that
remember we also have um new legislation
that was passed last year to relook at
the accountability process behind an
adequate education that um I can't
remember the house bill that was that
was signed but that developed a task
force to redefine what is currently
called our performance-based
accountability system our P bath system
so I think if you parallel it with that
and also with that task force work you'd
be able to get future data on how is
this topic being presented in schools
and what opportunities do students have
so I like I said I commend the topic
it's very important that our students
learn this but I think we have different
Pathways that this could take and and
have actually probably a greater impact
thank you for your question thank you
yeah rent McDon thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here you noted I
believe you said eight schools that you
know are definitely doing this and I
happen to know of some that are not is
there any harm to putting this into law
perhaps some students get an additional
hour but for others wouldn't it be like
their first hour would there be a
problem with putting a law and addition
to the Frameworks um I I don't think
there would be a problem with it I just
think there will be confusion around
what is the expectation and personally I
think putting it into the rules and the
Frameworks um the log is a the law is a
bit vague right it just says the history
of it but when you put it into the
curriculum Frameworks and the rules we
can spell out like spec like minimum
Knowledge and Skills around this topic
that we expect all schools so I don't
think there's a harm representative
McConnell but what I think is are we
going to create more discrepancies
across our schools when we might have an
opportunity to bring more consistency to
our schools thank you thank you for your
question thank you thank you very much
for being here thank you
do you want me to leave it on I'll leave
it on
um uh does anyone have any questions for
Diana Fenton is here and is available
for technical assistance would you like
to um provide
any
morning good morning thank you for
having me um for the record my name is
Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education as you all well
know but I will share with you very
briefly this morning I went over to the
conquered Police Department to pay my
parking ticket and there's a woman
standing in line and she turned around
and said well you look like a lawyer and
I said uh is it is it the law book that
gave it away and she said no it's your
face so I don't think I have to
introduce myself anymore because it's
written all over my face that I'm a
lawyer so it's great um very
briefly when we look at House Bill 7
749 um I would encourage the members of
this committee to look at it
holistically within the chapter and so
um if you open your law books to 485
that's where RSA 18911 begins and
18911 is one of the statutes that I
brought to your attention during the
training it is a statute that is uh
routinely brought before this committee
and it is instruction in National and
State history government and civics
there are numerous um technical
advisories on our website one of our
goals for this summer is to do a
holistic uh technical advisory on that
particular statute because it has been
modified and amended uh so many times um
it's interesting to me when I look at
this bill is introduced that it would
not amend
18911 rather it would um amend RSA 189
the entire section at 18
18911 creating a whole new section
um
11e and so that would be
after you have food Nutri nutrition
program 189 111b and I'm on page 489
learning disability teacher cursive
handwriting multipication tables it
would create a whole new
section and this was designed and
drafted by Olf
I will defer to how they created it I
would just like to put it for
consideration in front of this committee
to look at the placement of it
holistically and whether or not it does
belong in 18 18911 I'm not here to say
either way but I would just encourage
this committee to take a look at kind of
the statutory construction and where it
is placed and where it is proposed to be
I'm happy to take any questions and I
thank you for your
time uh yes representative Bon thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I actually I had noticed that
too since you've given me pre Reign to
look at my book and see what the
statutes are and that was one of my
questions that I had for you uh the
other question was one that was brought
up about um all high schools being
required um so to get a high school a
New Hampshire high school diploma do all
high schools private non-public what
whatever they're called do they all have
to follow the same uh requirements that
public high school students have to to
get a New Hampshire high school diploma
and I don't know the answer to that I'm
wondering if you do I will have to get
back to you on that particular question
but I would guide you to look at
18911 which again is instruction in
National and State history government
and Civics and it says in all public and
non-public schools in the
state and then I think um when you flip
the page to 186
Section 1 a it goes into more detail to
say in all public charter public and
non-public schools and so it's
interesting that it has that dichotomy
um I can get you an answer to your
question in terms of kind of the all of
the requirements but given the nature of
what we're talking about here history um
communism to me I'm going to look for
guidance in
18911 thank you
any further questions representative
Terry um we both heard the the previous
witness indicate that in eight schools
within her um jurisdiction or area that
communism currently is discussed a
variety of different from different uh
viewpoints economics for example um and
also heard though that that um the the
new standards will um make world history
a one a full Credit One credit rather
than a half a credit if in fact that is
correct and I don't doubt that that it
is could you just do you have any
knowledge as to what kind of discussions
took place what what the decision-making
process was and why world history will
now become a full credit uh instead of a
half a credit course uh in in the in the
current standards and you're referring
to the Ed
306s world history becoming a one credit
course rather than a half credit I I'm
not familiar with those discussions if
you're referring to the 306s I'm happy
to provide you a copy of those but I I
was not privy to any of those
discussions thank you thank you further
questions see none thank you very much
thank
you with that we will close the hearing
on
749 and we will yes uh just make sure
are we um at some point are we
acknowledging the signin
sheets have we have we read those into
the
record um you're may I free yes okay so
um with regard to 749 online there are
four support and 96 opposed and two
neutral I don't know about the blue
sheet I'm happy to go get it if you'd
like um we we can do that after okay
yeah thank you um we'll next open the
hearing on House Bill 431 establishing a
commission to review Draft rules related
to minimum standards for public school
approval and State academic standards
developed by the Department of
Education and um we will change the uh
notice on the bill that we're hearing
Damon thank
you thank you Mr chair and good morning
committee uh for those who in the
audience or online might not be aware I
am state representative hope Damon I
represent Sullivan District 8 the lovely
towns of aworth langon lster Goan
Washington Springfield s my hometown of
cordon and the City of Claremont and I
sit on education funding committee and
come in to visit with you guys from time
to
time HB 431 is a bill that Endeavors to
improve the process by which the minimum
standards of public education generally
known as the 306 rules are revised as
most of you know these standards Define
the Operation of our valued Public
Schools they are required to be revised
every 10 years although that does not
have to happen all at once as the
expiration dates are varied for
different parts of the
rules throughout the most recent
revision process there were many
concerns regarding who was included or
excluded from
participating in particular the
necessary voices of people working in
public education were only heard heard
because they advocated vigorously and
pushed for inclusion in the process just
as we would not want people with no
training education or real board
experience to be our surgeons I believe
we should not want public school rules
to be written only by those who have not
worked in public schools rather we need
a diversity of voices from many
perspectives who all value improving our
student outcomes HP 431 was drafted with
expert input from my constituent
Christine Downey who you just heard from
and will have expertise from again who
worked diligently throughout the last
revision process to bring forward
educator voices it creates a commission
of 19 members with expertise in
education the commission would review
all drafts of Education rules related to
minimum standards for public school
approval and State academic standards it
would submit its report to the
commissioner of education and the State
Board of Education within 120 days of
the publication of any rules draft from
the doe I'm going to just briefly review
lines uh page one lines 12 to 29 in
regards to the membership of the
commission I'm sure you all don't need
me to read to you but there are 19
members um composing the commission or
there would be including the school
administrators Association the School
principal's Association the association
for supervision and curriculum
development the commissioner of
Education or their dese three teachers
at each level so high school middle
school and Elementary and a member
chosen to represent State and National
expertise in the area of Competency
Based education would be appointed by
those other members of the commission so
it covers the broad spectrum of all the
levels of Education all the folks who
participate in how our kids get their
education I also want to highlight that
the commission is required to recommend
line language that supports Competency
Based education maintains high quality
minimum standards and utilizes research
and evidence-based practices and
strategies it should be abundantly
Apparent from the outpouring of
opposition recently to House Bill 283
that Granite Staters want to maintain
our existing high standards for public
education and these rules are the key to
being able to do
that transparency is an essential
Hallmark of a fair and functioning
democracy the commission is required to
report its recommendations to the
Department of Ed and the State Board of
Ed this is quite simply necessary to be
defined in statute as following the res
revision process during the last three
years has been an arduous task of
hunting digging and being styed to even
find out what the proposed revisions
might be we owe our citizens our voters
our students a fair transform
transparent informed process for all of
our legislative
work finally we are aware of the
proposed non-gain amendment that would
replace this bill with entirely
different legislation regarding special
education and the hearing for that this
thir
Wednesday I agree that there are
concerns to address in special education
and I very much appreciate that
education funding maybe if we could
stick to this bill we're not discussing
any future
Amendment okay
okay I will just say as the daughter of
a social studies teacher I learned about
democracy both in public school and
around the dinner table and I'm pretty
sure that my 95-year-old dad is cringing
as he watches our rules be used to
hijack this
bill I'm providing some copies of
constituent Communications that Express
great concern around that process and I
will close by saying that legislation
regarding special ed does not belong
this bill should not replace this to
create the needed Commission on the 306
rules I would urge the committee to
consider House Bill 431 on its own
merits and support it as drafted thank
you thank you questions representative
McDonald thank you Mr chair and good
morning representative you mentioned the
membership of the committee and said
specifically three High School teachers
three Middle School teachers for
elementary school teachers and I'm
looking at lines 24 through 25 page 1 my
question is why would these be appointed
by Nea and AF as these unions as opposed
organization they are the organizations
that are most connected to our Public
School teachers and most aware I believe
of the folks who would well represent
that
said obviously the bill is now in
committee but I would be open to
considering what other processes would
be appropriate I'm not wetted to that um
but I do think that that is a very
reasonable approach all right thank you
further questions see none thank you
very much thank
thank you I I didn't mean to interfere I
you uh thank you Mr chairman committee
thank you Mr chairman committee members
my name is David Trumble I'm from the
town of whereare I support this bill for
three reasons first the historical trust
in the teaching profession that
legislators and Rule makers have played
in the past the legislative history of
RSA 193 e2a as noted in the statement of
purpose for that stat statute documents
the widespread participation of the
public and Educators in the writing of
that statute which defines inadequate
education and the role of Educators in
the public and writing the public school
approval standards in the current C
Frameworks in other words teachers have
been involved in writing these laws and
rules all the way up till now until the
last session where they had a hard time
getting their voice heard um second the
public school Educators administrators
and curriculum special Specialists are
experts in the field of Education they
deserve at least a meaningful
opportunity to participate in the rules
at the listening sessions that were held
which I attended when the private
contractor who was hired to write the
rules was asked questions and how would
these changes take place in practice on
several occasions he said we don't know
how it will work out the teachers will
figure it out if it's going to be up to
the teachers to figure out how the rules
will be in practice they should have a
chance to participate also just by
comparison if you look at Professional
Engineers you have a statute which sets
up a New Hampshire Board of Professional
Engineers that has rule making Authority
that's made up of five people four of
whom are Professional Engineers now I'm
not asking that teachers be allowed to
write the 306 rules but they should
certainly have a significant voice in it
the last reason I support this bill is
that what happened in the last year I
think disregarded the opinions of
Educators administrators and the public
in two ways first there was a great deal
of secrecy the first year of the work
that was done was completely behind the
scenes then there were listening
sessions at the listening sessions when
people asked why are you doing this the
private contractor said don't get mad at
me I was told these things had to be in
the rules by the department 25 New
Hampshire media organizations filed a
right to no request to find out what had
been said they were turned down the
Department of Education claimed that
that the public had no right to know
what the private contractor was doing
because he was not a public official
that contractor went on to tell the
conquered monitor that everything that
he had done was
secret that's not transparency we have a
right to know law it's in our state
constitution this process that happened
did not live up to that the second thing
is that educator voices were ignored
eventually at the 11th Hour Educators
were given a seat at the table but even
then the con the con sessions that were
made I think were largely window
dressing the main core requests of the
Educators were denied and I'll give you
three examples first is the role of
teachers if you look at RSA 18924 that's
the old standard School law from 1919
and then look at the adequate
publication public education law from
2007 that's the one that followed after
The Londoner case they both contain
these words teachers they contain a form
of the verb to teach they contain the
mandate shall and they contain the
Mandate provide instruction the law
requires that teachers teach and provide
instruction that's a New Hampshire
policy for a 100 years the current
regulations instead of having teachers
providing instruction in classes say
that schools need only offer learning
opportunities and teachers testified at
these hearings that this is changing
schools from a place of learning to a
credentialing Center the second
objection was to remove removal of class
siiz limits which has one teacher to a
certain number of students depending on
if it's Elementary or High School
replaced with educator to student ratios
that's important because Educators under
the new RS means a teacher or a PA
professional in the word classroom was
removed and we were told by Mr Klein at
a hearing well maybe someday we won't
need classrooms anymore but the thing is
this is right now if you have 40
children in a school and say fourth
grade you have to have two classrooms
with one teach teacher in each classroom
they would each have 20 now that teacher
may have a parah in that classroom and
most School most classes do have a par
in a class B to be one student who needs
parah help under the current regs the
new ones those 40 children could be in
one room with one teacher in one perah
that's a weakening of the standards and
and that was testified in that case the
the school administrators from
Manchester said that will greatly affect
their behavior and the third area is the
changing of the word shall to May which
impacted whether or not children will
get art music physical education those
voices were not heard at the second jail
car hearing a state representative said
that she had read the entire set of 200
comments out of 500 pages of comments
there was only one positive comment I
personally attended six hearings at the
State Board of Education in both Shell
Car hearings I other than for the
private contractor I never heard a
single person testify in favor of the
rules the rules were passed through the
proper process but the process left out
the key voice of Educators
administrators this bill would go a long
way towards redressing that problem
thank you thank you any questions rent M
thank you Mr chair good morning Mr
Trumble good morning representative uh
what are your feelings about adding
parents as members of the commission
thank you that's a great question um and
I think that um there was a bill you may
remember you r on education two years
ago representative luno had a a bill
that was more robust than this and he he
would have set up a a commission of
parents business leaders politicians
Educators School administrators and they
would have had a much more involved role
in writing the regulations that was a
great bill but it couldn't get anywhere
this bill I see as a step to say okay if
we can't have what you just described a
more robust bill at least let teachers
and school administrators have a chance
to have a formal say in it so I I would
be very happy to have parents involved
in this and I don't I'm not speaking for
the people who wrote the Bill yeah so
thank you oh you're welcome thank you
uh thank you very much for being here
thank you Mr
Downey thank you again for allowing me
to speak chair in committee I am sending
around a copy of my written testimony I
don't intend to read it to you um I just
wanted to bring up a couple key points
uh the the first point I would break uh
bring up is that establishing this
commission would not cost the state
anything in this last round a soul
Source contract was paid out in the
amount of $75,000 for this work so this
proposal would not have any cost
implications to the states um I can
speak on behalf of almost 500 Educators
who volunteered their time for
approximately the year and a half that I
went around the state and conducted 306
review sessions they want to do this
work they get excited about this kind of
work and once they get excited they get
invested in wanting to make changes in
their schools and I think that's a
powerful thing the second point I would
bring out is two sections of the RSA I
think this commission supports the
intent um of two parts of RSA
193e and the first part that I really
think it it pulls out is under section
one part two where and I'm going to read
this because I think it's a powerful
statement and it speaks to what we
believe in New Hampshire and I think
that's what makes us such a high quality
um system of educational EXC Excellence
Across the Nation and that is respecting
New Hampshire's long tradition of
community involvement it is the purpose
of this chapter to ensure that
appropriate means are established to
provide an adequate education through an
integrated system of shared
responsibility between state and local
government and I think this commit
mission is something that really gets at
what does that mean in our rsas this is
what it means um represented McConnell I
loved your questions about parents I
would actually love to see high school
students on this commission I think it
would be super important to get some of
our students involved in the
conversation and if I had had more time
I probably would have done that around
the rules um the last thing I would p uh
point out in terms of um another part of
the RSA that I think really speaks to
the work of this committee is that in
RSA 193e it also indicates the general
court which is all of you shall ensure
that the high quality of the minimum
standards for public school approval in
each area of Education identified in
paragraph one is maintained and again I
think the establish this establishment
of this commission speaks to those key
founding principles what we value in New
Hampshire for our educational system um
the last thing I would just add that
hasn't really been brought up is um we
have precedent to establish commissions
like this um when it comes to our
minimum School approval uh rules and
defining an adequate education a couple
I'll just point out um one of them I
already pointed out which is the new
task force that's being developed around
accountability related to how schools
are meeting an adequate education the
other two I would point out is the um
current New Hampshire Civics commission
um which actually is doing some great
work in getting resources out to schools
in
consistency um and I the other one that
I would point out one of the great
commissions I love is the genocide and
Holocaust commission so we have
precedent and um examples of these
commissions and and if you look up those
commissions they in directly involve
families um parents community members
teachers um and we get great work when
we put all those stake play stakeholders
together so um I just I really value
this and I um think it's important um so
we are certainly open to other ideas
around it um so thank you for your time
tonight thank you very much represent U
try thank you and thank you for taking
my question could you go over again a
little bit how this wouldn't cost
anything and what where the funding
comes from yes thank you representative
drive so I haven't we haven't built into
the bill like any mileage requirements
um like some of the other commissions
pay out mileage they don't necessarily
offer stiens but they pay out mileage so
we didn't write anything in that and
really this would be a and the reason
why I'm saying I don't think there's a
cost to it is because these people would
be appointed um and they would be giving
of it would be volunteer time that
they're giving to it um you know and I
just think that's how we operate in New
Hampshire we're we're we're a
collaborative uh State you know where um
schools can get together and Share work
and collaborate so I'm yeah I mean I it
could certainly go through Finance to a
cost cost analysis but on Surface we're
not saying you need to pay these people
mileage anything like that thank you for
your question thank you and is there a
time table is this a a permanent
committee or commission that's setting
up I I think as we wrote it to be a
permanent commission set up so that it
constantly serve I I like to say is this
oversight can get iffy in that word I
like to say this is a nice Checks In
Balance to what we want the RSA to to do
to actually carry out in practice
between that that language around shared
responsibility that we all share in this
thank you thank
you R Murray thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question I am I'm
I'm curious with with regard to the
membership committee I think we talked
about parent
but one of the others I I went through
and looked twice um would you be opposed
to including the special ed community in
in any way to have a seat at the table
as absolutely not representative Murray
thank you for your question thank you
y not would not be opposed to it at all
no yeah she asked me if I would be
opposed to it sorry no no we would the
more ideas you guys can generate I think
we're open to it yeah yeah yes I would I
would include special education R
Woodcock thank you um not a question
particularly we just want to thank you
for all your work You' done with 306s
over this last year for all our
edification has been terrific thank you
representative Woodcock see no further
questions thank you very much okay thank
you and with that we'll close the
hearing on House Bill
431 and uh since we have a little bit of
time before lunch um we might exec a few
bills so um
um we can take a 10-minute Break um
caucus and talk about that um and then
come back at 11 o'clock and represent
Murray uh thank you Mr chair and just
for consistency here I just wanted to U
mention that the online portal for 431
was uh 688 uh in support 74 in oppose
and four
neutral thank
you yes um are you attending the
exective bill that identified for the
one
hour other bills those bills right other
other bills not the uh not these
not
um right other bills we can take up we
G right
yeah because they're on on the schedule
spe leadership knows what's happening
thank
C and the rest of us will be in caucus
minutes
e
so we will uh go back into um exact
session um well not back into ex EXA
session but we will start an exact
session uh briefly um and then we can
break for lunch um uh the uh the rest of
us on uh my side of the aisle will uh
cck us uh for a little while after we
finish um on the
exec
okay uh
I hand the gavl over to representative
Noble I open the executive session on HB
121 FN establishing local school
district special education parent
advisory councils and I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion
thank you I would like to move to
retain House Bill
121 is
second representative Cornell s um any
discussion representative cordelli uh
thank you um um I I think that the uh
discussion is centered around um the uh
committee how the committee is formed
and basically uh who forms the uh parent
advisory uh committee um I've looked at
multiple Alternatives and um I can't
agree with myself on what the right uh
path is um so uh I'd like to retain and
uh try and talk with some people you
know maybe from around the state who
have um these um advisory councils also
and representative u u oh you want to
call him represent B
bony or Corell
first representative
Cornell I I agree with um
chair
cordelli any other
discussion no no
retained chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes and chairman cordelli yes
Nays thank you um so next uh we'll take
up um oh yes well well it's retain it's
just
yes three people
yeah yeah we have we're only 15
360 and uh I'll call on representative
Noble as the prime
sponsor I move to
retain is there a second yes represent
McDonald uh just disc yes thank you Mr
chair um this bill is actually more
proactive uh much of what we do around
here is reactive um and I would like to
be able to take a little bit more time
to do my due diligence uh with it over
over the summer and fall
so that's it repr down anything uh no
further comments thanks thank you any
other comments from uh committee
members seen
none Madam
clerk the motion is to retain Vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes representative dry yes
representative yes
representative McDonald yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
baloni yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
z um thank you very much
um I think that that completes what we
can do this morning we have a number uh
scheduled for um this afternoon and uh
more on
Wednesday um uh while everyone's out to
lunch um there is an amendment to House
Bill
699 um that I'll leave for everybody on
on their uh
desk and um we'll uh come back at uh 1
o' resent Murray is that something that
you can give to us now that we can take
a look at it oh sure yes I can yeah I'll
um that's in
yeah no $6.99 I have copies of now n
yeah right I um I think we have copies
of the other the second there's two
amendments for 90 right I think we have
right just have to have copies made of
one of them and the other one's in
drafting Okay so so I'll get you those
okay
e
know I think we're ready to get
started um we have a number of bills
um and um the first one on our list um
in the calendar is
hb90 um but there is an amendment
pending um that we don't have yet so
we'll hold that off until Wednesday
Wednesday um so we'll start with uh
House Bill
108 which is relative to bullying and
cyber bullying across multiple school
districts
and uh call upon representative McDonald
for uh a motion I think you've been
working on this thank you Mr chair I
move opop pass and with your permission
I'd like to move a further
motion thank you is there a second for
the opop
Murray um discussion and you have
something further yes also like to move
Amendment 0839
H and you all should have a copy of that
provided today and this replaces the
previous amendment that I provided
during the work um work session for this
bill second to the am second by
representative Terry for the
amendment
H uh would you like to speak to your
motion representative McDonald yes so
the amendment replaces the bill except
the effective date which remains
unchanged it's still 60 days after
Passage
um just to recap a little bit of the
discussion we had of how we got to this
point we were talking about who would
initiate the investigation for bullying
we determined that it would be best for
all of the districts involved to
collaborate but so somebody would have
the role codified in statute it would be
the Principal or designate of the first
district to learn of the incident then
we had somewhat agreed on a consensus
for the bill absent the fact that we
heard during testimony I believe from
the Department that the bill would be
ineffective in other states so how would
we address cross District bullying cyber
bullying over state lines and so that's
where you're looking at the last
sentence and this begins on line 15 ends
on line 18 it's short so I'll read it to
you in cases of bullying and or cyber
bullying across multiple States the
principal or designate of the first
district located within New Hampshire to
learn of the incident shall contact the
New Hampshire attorney's General's
office reason I settled on the Attorney
General we had some discussion on which
groups be contacted offline we had
mention of perhaps the department of
safety perhaps the Human Rights
Commission we heard during testimony for
another bill on a completely unrelated
topic also brought up the Human Rights
Commission and we had heard that there
is a delay in getting results back from
them and when bullying may be a pressing
issue as it relates to self harm or
perhaps suicidal ideation we don't have
that time to wait in these worst cases
so we determin that the Attorney General
most appropriate if they choose to
forward it to the Human Rights
Commission we leave that up to them and
I also had another concern what if there
is a false report the Attorney General
can decide perhaps it's best not to act
on this and just leave that up to them
in these extreme cases across States
perhaps or more highrisk cases as well
so that is the amendment in front of you
thank
you now would the second like to comment
on only to say that in in some I believe
that the concerns that were expect that
were expressed during the hearing and in
discussion subsequent that um that the
amendment uh addresses those concern in
a very positive way and uh would
strengthen the bill if uh we're adopted
so uh I agree thank you thank you resent
Murray um thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh to representative McDonald for
working on this as well um I did just
want to Note One SM small well a I don't
know if it's small that a minor thing
these are allegations of bullying and or
cyber bullying and so that was
potentially the only thing that I
thought could need a further
clarification at some point but I you
know I I see the intent here so I just
wanted to make sure that these are
initial
allegations um prior to a
investigation representa if I may I
appreciate those comments and also if
you are not aware representative has
invested quite a bit of time in this
bill as well so I appreciate that um in
regards to allegations I was careful in
the wording of this to not include words
such as perpetrator or Victim Because
prior to an investigation we don't know
who's responsible and again I had talked
to the Attorney General's office
regarding false reporting so I believe
the language is clear on that point but
I would not be opposed to subsequent
legislation in future years but I am
strongly encouraging that this committee
passes something on this issue this year
so it's not delayed so I would not want
to let perhaps the perfect be the enemy
of the good but I would not be opposed
conversations uh seeing none um Madam
amendment PR chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tzar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative Damon yes representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass yes
chairman cordelli yes 17 Ys zero Nays
thank you uh do you have a further
motion representative McDonald I would
move a to pass on House Bill 108 as
amended by
0839 thank you representative Murray
seconds discussion or are we uh done
done discussing uh no further
discussion great thank you any other
questions for we vote on The
otpa Madam Clerk and this is
House Bill 108 with Amendment 03 excuse
me 08
39h Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero nay
consent yes great thank you uh next
let's turn to uh House Bill
673 which was also on the bullying
topic relative to school bullying and
discrimination
plans um do I have a motion
representative McDonald yes thank you Mr
chair I move
itl thank you is there second I'll
representative
Freeman thank you represent McDonald
yeah to keep this brief I appreciate the
sponsor's intent with this bill
especially to address bullying however
the bill that we just passed I think
addresses a lot of the concern so for
that reason I move in expedient to leg
slate R Freeman anything um I'll
reiterate what representative McDonald
sayate and um agree that this bill would
be duplicative of the bill we just
passed thank you further discussion
representative Murray uh thank you Mr
chair I actually um though I understand
um the the motion I would prefer to
retain it in the event that some other
um as another potential vehicle um in
the event that something were to happen
to 108 um but I do understand that that
is the motion that you've brought
forward
any further
discussion uh see none Madam clerk when
you're ready motion is itl vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
wood Co yes repres representative Hall
yes representative Balon yes
representative
Damon representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 17 yay zero
nay consent without objection great
thank
you have next I had was
555 let's take up uh House Bill 55
might let me just mention as we're
turning our Pages um appreciate uh
whoever is making a motion uh this
afternoon
um uh that requires either a majority
Andor Minority Report that we have the
reports um in um end the day tomorrow if
we could so make sure we get them into
the calendar um for as soon as possible
because we have a number uh pending to
point so House Bill
555 uh representative Freeman does you
have a motion yes thank you Mr chair um
I move in expedient to
legislate is there a
second representative Terry thank
you uh reverent Freeman did you have
discussion on your motion briefly um um
there were a few problems with bit this
bill but one of the largest concerns
that I have and I think that some of my
colleagues will agree that this really
does interfere with the local control
issue um we don't know currently what
schools are teaching about these two
subjects if at all teaching about them
and I believe requiring any type of of
curriculum um is an overreach um in of
the legislature so for that reason I
will ask all of my colleagues to vote in
expedient to
legislate represent Terry well speaking
of control Mr chairman um the um the uh
the problem with the orig the bill is
was originally drafted and submitted to
us was that it was very specific as to
which genocides um should be included
the problem with the bill as the amend
the requested amendment was that it was
going we were going to be relying on uh
International bodies to determine uh
what constituted genocide so for those
two reasons in addition to the reason
cited by representative Freeman I would
urge itl thank you any further
discussion representative Cornell I
believe we also got a statement from the
Holocaust and genocide commission that
um meets Reg ly and discuss that and one
of their points was that they discuss
ongoing events that may constitute
crimes against humity war crimes ethic
cleansing or genocide so I think they
keep up to dat with it and and I think
we can rely on them to to make sure that
they include anything that needs to be
included thank you any further
discussion see none um Madam clerk when
you're ready thank you m itl Vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative bbon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
Cordell
yes 17 yay zero Nays consent without
great okay let's uh next turn to House
Bill 75
53 relative to expedited due process
hearings to enforce special education
rights
oh yeah
right
um do you want to make the motion or do
you want me to want me to make the
motion do you
want well you already opened correct
yeah
um I recognize representative cordelli
motion uh yes I'd like to move out to
pass on House Bill
second representative Freeman seconds is
there a
discussion uh just that I I think that
this um tries to make sure that
expedited due process hearings are
expedited
any discussion from the
second and I'll expedite
that I agree with everything that
representative Celli
said any other
discussion seeing none Madam
clerk motion is ought to
pass Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representa litfield yes representative
McDonald yes representative tenar yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
balbon yes representative Damon yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes chairman cordelli yes 17 y
zero
Nays consent okay everybody great thank
you
okay
y we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 324 FN relative to
prohibiting obscene or harmful sexual
materials in schools and I recognize
representative cordelli for a motion
uh thank you madam chair uh I would move
second representative Terry
seconds a discussion from the maker of
the
motion uh thank you
um this legislation um tries to
accomplish um several things one is to
put in place a minimum
process by which parents can object to
materials that they believe are age
inappropriate or harmful to minors uh in
their
schools um and sets in process this
minimum uh
process um
secondly it eliminates from the criminal
code an exemption for K12 education
realizing that uh it would be a very
rare
circumstance for a criminal case uh to
be brought um in these
instances um but uh I felt that um uh
it's um not a good signal to the public
that um K12 is exempt from our uh our
Obsession excuse me obscenity laws and
the third thing it does is it does set
forth the possibility for uh civil uh
penalties um if uh in um limited
circumstances um which is on page four
um that a uh
decision that has been made in relation
to the materials uh is not adhered to um
that would uh open up the possibility
for uh civil action
um so I think that this is reasonable
legislation we we have heard for several
years uh about uh materials being found
in schools that are harmful uh to
miners um and certainly age
inappropriate and I think that this is
another attempt to address that to the
schools any comments from the second yes
uh in addition to uh the comments made
by the maker of the
motion I have with respect to this bill
I have seen more than I thought that I
would ever see
I have heard more than I thought I would
ever
hear this bill is for our children and
we need to pass
it any other
discussion representative
Alon uh thank you um so in speaking to
this bill that we have heard for several
years now um it really is um up to it's
a local control issue uh schools already
have many policies in place to deal with
their Library Collections and which
books are available to particular
students there's also a way in which uh
parents that object to the materials
that are there have recourse in which to
um have them reviewed uh what this
policy what this bill will do is it
actually removes the uh local Authority
and and puts that up onto the State
Board of Education to determine what
books uh can uh be available to students
in local districts and I think that is
an overreach right there because I
believe that um people here at the State
Board don't necessarily know what what
my what's appropriate for children in my
school in Ry um it really is another
case
where certain parents are being given
the opportunity to decide what every
student has access to an in a library
and that's really overriding parental
control if I want my child to be able to
read a book um and having somebody else
say no that book can't be available to
my child um there are already laws
available uh that prevent giving miners
harmful materials and this book and this
bill has a vague terms in it um and I
also have issues with the Civil
penalties that could um
um increase uh legal cost to districts
for those uh uh um for the parents to
take it up to the next level um so no I
will not be voting in favor of this Bill
thank
you any other
discussion representative wock thank you
and um I can't do any better than what
representative Bon probably screwed up
by talking more but I do feel when you
have one parent identifying what can
cannot be in a public school library uh
that's very limited to the rest of
people in population that they have no
option to even see a book or have the
youngsters see the book parents right
now have the option to say no you can't
read it the parents can tell the
youngsters you can't go on that line you
can't get this book don't do this um
we're not doing that this we're taking
actually the control out of the parents
we're limiting everyone in the school
except that one family and I think
that's uh wrong we we now Lose A
diversity of novels and books and genres
that people need to hear and read people
can see themselves in those books thank
you representative dry
thank you and thank
um I'm not reading that in this bill
because I'm looking at the complaint
process is that the school Bo each local
school board shall adopt a complaint
resolution policy consistent with this
section complaints are made and writing
to the principal they're taken uh within
14 calendar days the school principal or
designes decide this it's not the hands
of the parents that make the complaint
it's the hands of the process that the
local school board has brought up
repr cordelli thank you uh just follow
up on a couple of things um one in terms
of the State Board involvement um the
State Board is involved anyway
regardless of the language in um this
bill
um as indicated in this bill it is part
of the duties of the State Board of
Education and they're found on page 15
in our books to hear appeals and issue
DEC ISS of any dispute between
individuals and school
systems so that's in law already and
this is just repeating that
statute um secondly it's been charged
that we are um Banning
books that is not uh the case um we are
um providing for the fact that there
might be books that are in a section of
the library at a certain grade level
that are age
inappropriate um or harmful to minors
and providing the option for the uh
school and School District to move those
books to another section or a higher
grade level uh to comply with the um
through the complaint and the
findings
um uh I've also heard the argument made
that uh School libraries in effect ban
books when they decide what books to
bring into the library to
acquire um so I think that this is um
reasonable legislation uh to address
what um I and many consider a problem in
some
schools represent Mar yes in addition to
the many other things that um
representative Boni and Woodcock have
spoken to one of the other things that I
see enumerated here in statute is um a
violation fee which is normally set by a
court of law anyway for uh recouping
fees or legal fees like that um and I I
find it very interesting that we are
putting the fine in statute
um if a party decides to seek uh action
and legal action through a court of law
representative Bon um thank you um just
one other point to uh what was just what
uh chairman cordelli just referenced it
isn't just about um age appropriateness
it does say that the material can be
remove removed or restricted and I would
just put out there that uh it's pretty
arbitrary sometimes to determine what is
age appropriate I mean what is age
appropriate I might decide is more age
appropriate for my child and then
another parent might decide that they
don't think it's age appropriate for
their child so again it comes down to
you represent litfield thank you madam
chair
so I'm assuming that we can't share this
with the public as far as a graphic is
concerned as far as holding up the
picture but what I'd like to say because
as it's being put out there to the
public right now we look so evil like
we're trying to censor kids we're
Banning books or parents don't know best
we had people come in this room and
share with us actual pictures from books
that are in some of them elementary
schools um we have a male giving orals
well doesn't matter I care for you male
or female someone giving oral sex to
someone else a graphic picture um we
have someone at summer camp and they're
passing around bottles to put their
semen in these are kids we've got an
example of cutting we're giving kids
ideas putting thoughts in their head um
I've seen today more examples of people
having anal sex and using whips these
are in our schools that is pornography
any other discussion representative
Freeman thank you madam
chair for all the reasons representative
litfield said but I'd like to point
something out parents have asked us to
do this this wasn't an idea in a
vacuum this wasn't something
that representative cordelli just pulled
out of the air and decided to put in a
bill on parents have begged us to do
this the same parents who are pulling
their children out of public schools for
educational options we need to listen to
them we need to respect these parents
they want what's best for their children
and if they don't feel that this
material is appropriate for their child
we need to put a mechanism in place that
says we heard you we care and we will
make sure that your child doesn't get
this material I think this is pretty
common sense
the parents have asked us to do this and
we need to respect
that any other comments representative
Damon thank you madam
chair there is nothing being addressed
in this proposed
legislation that can't be accessed
online very
efficiently and our students are doing
that anyway I personally would rather
that they have access at the discretion
of parents
where it can be discussed with the
parents and I would also represent that
there may I'm sure our parents who have
asked for this there are far more
parents who have asked for us not to
censor throughout history when
censorship begins it gets more and more
severe over time I don't think the US is
that
countryes representative cor did you
she's okay representative Hall Madam
chair um when we want to listen to the
parents uh online testimony in against
the bill
1,355 and for 47 so we're listening to
the parents those numbers mean
something representative
litfield I I'll come back to the numbers
in just a moment but I would like to
talk about um these library books or
these books that are in the schools we
have a bill right now um that is going
through the state house and I hopefully
it's moved on to this I don't know if
actually we're going to hear it in the
house soon to vote on it but the bottom
line is it's to give parents access to
their child's Library records parents
don't even have access to that right now
so we're giving pornography to miners so
I know you're talking about censoring
we're not censoring 18 and over we're
talking about age appropriateness for
children and what's happening now is
parents can't even go to the school
library or the public library to find
out what their child has taken out so
actually the parent has no idea what the
child is seeing and regarding the
numbers I understand that we are being
asked to read these out loud and I agree
it's very important and online testimony
is absolutely just as important as
someone coming in here because not
everyone can make it in here but what
concerns me is we represent the people
of New Hampshire and I don't know where
all of this online testimony is coming
from is it coming from Germany China is
it coming from California I don't know
me representative bbon thank you um I'm
just wondering is this is this bill
about actually um making the process
better or is it actually about getting
materials out of libraries um what what
bill you want to address that sure uh as
as it says in the bill this is the
voice could I if I could expand on a
couple of other things while I have the
mic um that I heard you may thank
you yeah uh yes another
question thank you um uh in terms of um
the access and kids getting a hold of
materials on the internet and so forth
um as we had demonstrated in the hearing
um there is the
Sora app on school materials that
provides access
to this
information um and secondly um in terms
of
um um refining or confining um access um
uh as was testified to also um we have
rating system for M for movies U for
minors um there is no such rating system
for uh
for books although I believe Texas has
looked into trying and doing that but um
uh uh you know book publishers might
listen to Texas but I don't think that
they're going to listen to legislation
Hampshire of
all thank you madam chair um a couple
things when we heard from the the lady
testifying about four years ago and she
had the links to that book program and
it was taken near Match.com and all that
stuff I don't believe that happens in
school I think that that happens when
they go home because in school those
Chromebooks have the filters on them so
they go home and they no longer have the
filter so parents can check that out in
the other part when we talk about
parental access all they need to do is
say what's your passcode you have a you
have a 10-year-old what's your passcode
and go on there and see what your kid is
reading they can you can access it right
if you have your kids's password you can
reading person thank
you thank you um this a response to my
friend across the hallway here um porn
pornography the youngst is illegal we ar
PR we ar providing
pornography in the school for youngsters
it's illegal
the when we say we're not Banning books
when a parent comes in and complains
about this book about the genre about
the author about the character about the
plot and it's taken out that book's not
there it's
banned as clear as that the third thing
is if parent and I'll follow up
representative Hall's eloquent comments
if parents want to control the students
then that's parents responsibility you
should not be telling me or the
librarian what my child can see use and
not use that thing if I have a complaint
with it that's me and my child clearly
shouldn't do that you can access exactly
what your child has got to school by
asking them just talk to you I don't
want to do this but the bottom line is
they can't do it no one can do it you're
telling me no one can do it if you don't
like it not parent that's what bothers
me thank you representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair and uh to further
the conversation on the um testimony of
the individual who was able to get
clickthrough links to some other I
believe they were displaying a personal
cell phone that um had no filters
applied to it so I I to your point I I
understand that um the the other the
other point that I would U like to speak
to is with regard to um the assertation
that we do not know where the online
testimony is coming from every
individual registers their opinion
online with a town and a state location
so you can see that um online uh for the
record I just wanted to make that clear
representative dve thank you so I was
taking notes during that meeting and I
believe that the woman with the
Chromebook had her daughter's app it was
on her
daughter's thing and it was what her
daughter had access to during the school
day and she went right from that to the
hyperlink and I'm going to still say
that we're not talking about one parent
or um taking a book out of a library
we're talking about one parent making a
complaint to the school board which has
set its policy once that there it's out
of their hands it doesn't matter if it's
one person or 40 people it's still going
to be the same process and it's going to
be somebody else's decision not
theirs represent
Lichfield thank you madam chair so for
this particular bill I promised my last
time because we go back and forth right
um but what I want to say is regarding
you're talking about online testimony
how you have to put an information um
this is something that you can probably
check with with the speaker's office at
this point or maybe the clerk but as I
sat in house session on Thursday morning
my seatmate received an email and it was
an anti-a email this email had a
signature or you know what I'm saying
the person's name was written their
address was written and it was funny
because he laughed and he said do you
know what he said this is my neighbor
and she's been dead for a couple years
and do you know what the spouse is dead
too they don't even have that house
anymore he received this email during
house session and what's even funnier
ironic he's a police
officer anyway um talking about messages
just where's the point of order it's
inappropriate for us to be denigrating
people testifying online which is the
implication of the prior speaker's
remarks I I I don't think she
was denigrating anyone testify online
she was poting out an incident that
session any other comments regarding
this
bill just one interesting comment so
this message from the dead it came
through the email was during the house
session when you're not supposed to have
the cell phones on is that the one
that's
comments seeing none Madame clerk motion
is
OTP Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell no
representative Murray no representative
Woodcock absolutely no representative
Hall no Representative bbon no
representative Damon no Representative
kuger no representative Snodgrass no and
okay uh representative bbon will do the
Minority Report and itl and the motion
[Music]
754 yeah we'll add
it
um okay we're I think going to bring up
one final bill but um I think that we
need to caucus about it before we
actually uh debate it so if we could
take a a brief caucus and it will be a
house bill uh
653 relative uh to a pilot program um
temp ment alternatives for restraint and
[Music]
seclusion
e
is is back um thank you for that uh few
minutes and we'll take up House Bill
653 establishing a pilot program within
the Department of Education to implement
alternatives to restraint and seclusion
of students and representative Freeman
did you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I move um
Cornell uh represent Freeman did you
have a motion uh excuse me discussion on
your motion um very briefly um I think
at this juncture any any program that
will um try to explore alternative to
restraint and seclusion of some of our
most troubled students is um is a
positive step um in finding out where we
can mitigate any damages but also um
help these
children thank you representative
Cornell okay further
discussion repres Marie um thank you Mr
chair yes I agree uh with the atop pass
motion as well and I I in addition to uh
students who may be quote troubled there
are a myriad of other instances in which
um this may um
uh restraint or seclusion may be used
and and seeking alternate or alternative
methods would be a study would be much
appreciated thank you correct yes and
and this is again just a pilot program
to explore those Alternatives
so any further
discussion I see none Madam
clerk motion is ought to pass Vice
chairman Noble yes representative Terry
yes yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
NATO yes representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
Damon yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero Nays great
sense okay with everybody yeah
great so I I think that that completes
our work for
today um we'll most likely have a busy
day
Wednesday um and I'd ask uh for those
who are doing reports um if you could
have them to me by the end of the day
tomorrow um we want to get things moved
along over to the clerk's office and out
of our hands as soon as possible
and
um uh rent Cordell will uh get you a
copy of this sheet although you probably
can remember it without too much
difficulty and uh thank you very much
for um five five bills on the consent
calendar
today great so thank you very much and